uh this is a reason uh live stream uh
it's Zach Weissmuller my colleague and
we're talking to Michael Heist the uh
founder and uh supreme commander of the
mises caucus the uh uh segment of the
libertarian party which took over
control of the party uh last whatever it
was May June uh at the Reno convention
at the Reno reset he also runs the mises
pack which is political action uh
Coalition uh Michael
um I guess let's start off with talking
about the uh decentralized Revolution
document the mises [ __ ] has dropped
earlier this year project decentralized
Revolution for a new libertarian party I
hear Echoes of Murray rothwartz for a
new Liberty in that title uh but uh give
us the what's the elevator pitch what is
Project decentralized Revolution
so Echoes of of Murray rothbard as well
as Ron Paul with the uh Revolution there
but um but so the elevator pitch is
we're the the point of the Takeover was
always to develop a political strategy
in the long term for the political for
the political party that is the lp uh
and to this point I don't think there
has been a cohesive strategy I I for as
long as I can remember as long as I can
tell uh I think there's just kind of
been this well we just want to run
candidates we just want to get ballot
access uh and and nothing that kind of
is sustainable in the long term and so
the effect of that has been to kind of
spin our wheels for a while and there's
a lot of people who have done a lot of
good work but we've we've got to develop
something in the long term
um and and something that takes stock of
where we're at within political reality
right now as a third party and what's
realistic for us and attainable for us
and use that as a foundation to build
into the future five years 10 years 15
20 years yeah what what's the Core
Essence because I it's true it's it's a
long range strategy a strategy document
but you know what's what's kind of at
the core of the strategy
well again the the beginning of the
document is a lot about kind of
accepting maybe some bitter truths you
know and and shooting for the top is not
helping us and it's not it's not helping
us to earn trust and in the concept of
trust is something that is repeated over
and over again in that document and and
so basically what we're saying is we
should shoot locally but when I say
locally it's just the same as I said in
the our first interview at Reno we got
to shoot for city council we got to
shoot for mayor Sheriff judge School
Board seats that are are uh able to do
something about our problem with the
federal government today that uh also
like put us in the mix in the culture at
the local level because what I believe
is that you know we're being trained to
believe that culture is something that
is dictated from the top down because of
the fact that the political left and the
progressives have essentially taken over
the institutions of the country and
they're using those institutions to push
ideology through culture and and I and I
don't think that's organic in any sense
I think culture is something that
emerges naturally from the individual
through the family and through the
community so in a very real sense if we
say okay we're going to take it to this
community level the culture is what
we're mixing it up with in real time and
at the same time that local level is
where Americans at large perceive the
political Stakes to be the lowest and
therefore most likely to maybe listen to
us and not at the highest level where
they uh where they perceive the stakes
to be the highest where they don't
believe that we're going to win so we've
got a Commodities here too it's a lot
easier to get somebody to vote for a
Libertarian dog catcher or even tax
assessor at the county level than uh
present
again city council I don't care about
dog catcher I don't care about things
that can't uh materially change our
position uh with with the with the
federal government
I I want to dig a little bit more into
the the strategy for winning local
elections and and how you plan to select
what kind of Elections to run for but I
want to back up for a second to
something else you said about accepting
the political reality because that's
kind of how this this document opens and
I'm just going to read from this a bit
at length and get you to expand on uh
one of the ideas here
um this is a section called accepting
political realities
um we must accept certain realities
about the political landscape in the
United States and where third parties
are within that landscape some of this
may be bitter medicine as you said but
it's crucial that we get real with
ourselves
um the ruling class with its allies in
the corporate media and Academia waged a
subtle divide and conquer campaign
against the American people in the last
century or so and it has largely
succeeded the electorate has been
conditioned to identify with either team
red or team blue and to take part art in
Fierce political debate and life or
death battle with a very constricted
range of opinions and topics which are
sometimes called the Overton window and
you go on that this team mentality is
not merely political it's psychological
and emotional and to leave one's team
which is what Libertarians are asking
people to do is to leave one Social
Circle and Status it's a significant
price to pay and we have to have a
compelling reason to ask people to make
that sacrifice
so I guess my my opening question uh off
of that is what are the immediate steps
that you're taking or how does that uh
integrate into your strategy to break
people out of that very ingrained red
blue mentality what is the compelling
what are the compelling reasons
um that the new libertarian party plans
to put forth
so it's it's a it's a multitude of
things like At first stated kind of
tamping down our ambition about where
we're actually going to win I think
that's a big part of it because then we
can kind of come to people where they're
at and where they're willing to maybe
make a change whereas they won't be at
the federal level or something like that
um and then other than that we've also
got to meet them where they're at on the
issues that are of overlap with us
because in my opinion the name of the
game is trust we have to earn trust and
this is something that is a little bit
more psychological than how we talk
about ideas and how we how we want to
advance our ideas and and how people are
going to accept ideas is determined by
what you might call their psychic
environment or their social environment
um and you kind of appear you have to
pierce through all of that so what I'm
saying is there is a lot of distrust in
politicians right now there's a lot of
people on the political left who are not
getting what they want from their their
uh political class there's a lot of rank
and file on the political right who are
not getting what they want on their
political class and so we can exploit
those gaps and and come in on the issues
and basically push the the political
right the actual politicians with their
Rank and file behind us to actually pass
gun sanctuary legislation at the local
level or at the county level you know or
drug decriminalization if you live in a
left area and all that kind of stuff and
this goes to both create Liberty in the
the locality that you're in give you
Street credit because maybe they still
think of the libertarian party as a joke
but now they see you personally as a
doer and you've achieved something that
they want I fundamentally don't think in
some sense we can even have the
conversations really in good faith until
there's a level of trust because of this
team environment the the social
environment of it is to you know not
listen to us until we either a or a
threat to them B can help them destroy
their enemies or C create trust and we
just don't have the political Capital to
be a direct threat or a direct Aid to
helping them destroy their enemies so
we've got to figure out how to generate
Trust what's the uh what's the timeline
on this
oh God this is going to be multiple
decades long uh and that's that's you
know it's you can get elected into a
city council today but in order the idea
is that as I stated in the article that
this is gonna Liberty is gonna have to
be successful as a cultural movement
before it could ever be success hope to
be successful as a political movement
and that takes time and it takes kind of
the the seeds that we're planning at the
local level to flower over time and
collectively shift that culture to where
we can make bigger changes down the line
this is something that the progressives
have been doing for a hundred years and
and so you know it could take that long
but I I think at the very least if we
try it out in the five year
and and start to see progress we would
have therefore have
the emotional Fuel and the proof of
concept that we need to see what happens
in the next five years in the next five
years tweaking along the way as we need
to in new data and new experiences come
in but the shooting for the top thing is
not working and and again it's not it's
not generating trust because as far as
people can tell
they they don't they don't interact with
the libertarian party they don't see us
they don't see us in their communities
they just see us come up every two four
years or whatever in their in their
presidential races in their Senate races
and [ __ ] up their candidates and stuff
like that and then to disappear back
into the ether again only re-emerge two
four years later we that's not a trust
building exercise just a real quick note
you had mentioned uh the the document is
attributed to Aaron Harris who is Aaron
Harris
so here's our communications director um
it was a collaborative effort between
myself Aaron Harris and uh David Hines
you know they helped me editorialize it
in fact that's I was just curious
exactly so the the way that it seems
like you want to get Libertarians to
gain that trust uh is to get them into
offices that are kind of the low-hanging
fruit uh well well it's like it's both
like
offices that are very local and maybe
not a lot of people vote in these
elections but also they are uh they they
have kind of levers uh that can be
pulled to actually achieve change I I
found this section to be kind of
interesting
um you said only nine percent of the
673 LP candidates were for local office
which is you define as lower than county
level yet all but one of the 22 LP
victories were in those local races
um and then there's a kind of
extrapolation as to if if you kind of
expanded that strategy what the numbers
might have been but my question I guess
from just very mechanical point of view
is what is the plan to identify you know
how do you go about identifying good
offices to run for and good people to
run for those offices because that seems
like really the the task of of the
political party right
so two well the two things there and and
uh one is both of them are outlined in
the document so what I propose is the
year one uh strategy at a state party
level is and and this is happening this
year in Pennsylvania this is kind of the
Prototype uh you know our team here that
I'm I'm basing this off of they went
county by county and looked at the
Municipal elections from the previous
time that they had Municipal level
elections uh and essentially what they
found was that there was dozens in our
state at least dozens of city councilors
and mayors that one where the entire
race had less than 50 votes not just one
candidate the entire race had less than
50 votes so you can then set your sights
in on those and say okay this is the
absolute lowest hanging fruit of
positions that actually matter and start
to then send out
um you know mailers and and uh
recruitment efforts and and membership
drives towards those areas to get people
to run and then what I kind of tie in
there is that again because the
political part or the because the
libertarian party has not really had a
political strategy they don't really
have anything to to inform their
fundraising strategy and if you don't
have anything that that does either of
those you don't really have a
recruitment strategy the recruitment
strategy is well our ideas are awesome
and that's all well and good but we need
to have an Avenue uh to make those ideas
win in order for people to have you know
the psychic motivation to do the
drudgery that this is going to require
and and um so by having an actual
political strategy you can then ask for
money on the basis of that strategy to
get the tools needed to maximally do
that strategy which then allows you to
go out to say all these registered
Libertarians who are not in the party or
at least the ones that vote regularly
and say listen we're getting our [ __ ]
together we have an actual strategy it's
different now we want you in we can hook
you up with tools we can get you
experience helping these candidates yada
yada get them into the community and
then once the once the community element
takes oh that's the other thing the
community element is crucial to all of
this I don't think think any strategy
will work without a comprehensive
Community element from which a culture
of Liberty can emerge what do you mean
by that what what's uh what's so
Community strategy
well it goes back to this idea that
we're going to have to be successful as
a cultural movement and and you know I
outside of the presidential elections
you don't see events you know like look
at the Tom Woods 2000 uh episode event
there was 2 000 people at that event
that's bigger that that's bigger than
any presidential campaign I can think of
within the lp in their events we've got
to do things to bring people together
and get them connecting and getting our
creatives together supporting our
entrepreneurs and and that's what I mean
like we have to bring the people
together and then start supporting each
other in our projects whether we're
doing political based projects or not
um and then a culture and our creatives
our artists all of this stuff so that a
culture of Liberty Liberty can emerge
because again this isn't just political
an idea ideas we have to offer something
in the social realm for people if
they're gonna leave their old Social
Circles we have to have a robust
community so if we have that robust
Community when we invite people in it's
not just bickering and fighting and
eight people at a meeting and all of the
this stuff that's kind of characterized
the lp experience to this point you know
it's we have a strategy we have a
community we have a reason for you to do
the the kind of work that we're asking
you to do in the long term
just to get uh real specific about uh
the political strategy
um because obviously the libertarian
party has run local candidates for a
long time
um what where what would be different
here
um is that you're it seems like you're
saying it's this the state Affiliates
are the ones that would be really the
ones employing the strategy it's not
it's not like the national party is
suddenly
uh funding you know city council races
if I'm understanding it correctly it's
the state's chapter would be funding
these really local races is that
fundamentally different than how things
have worked in the past I don't think
there's been a focus on it I think
there's just been a we want people to
run man so like do what you want instead
of like this focus of well we've got a
campaign and we've got these tools and
we're going to do this and we're going
to do that and we've got volunteers and
we're aiming at these races because a
lot of times people come in there's no
there's a lack of infrastructure and and
and a lack of experience so when people
come in they have no direction and as
much as you know like we are
individualists and all of that people do
need leaders and I don't mean political
leaders I mean they I mean competence
leaders you know like they and and so
people do look to leaders to tell them
to help guide them in a Direction so we
have to have that in place for people
too not just say hey you know come in
and run for whatever race and you're
definitely not going to win and you know
just do whatever your own division it's
like no we've got an infrastructure in
place it's aimed at these races and for
this goal are you with us
and then what is the role of the state
level offices because you do mention
that it's not that you're going to
abandon running for Senator or uh
governor and so forth but that it's
going to be really targeted so how do
you decide what to do at the state level
in my opinion the state level is like a
microcosm of of running for president
um they are essentially marketing and
recruitment campaigns and they should be
used to maximize the other efforts that
are built around actually gaining
political Capital whether that be City
councilor and all of that so you know
they're the ones who have the perhaps
the widest microphone you know we got we
had several Senate candidates and uh
governor candidates this year that who
were able to get into the debates so
those are the people who have perhaps
the best opportunity within their state
to drive the messaging Drive the
Recruitment and and give a vision of
what it means to be a Libertarian and
what our culture is like to then drive
people towards us and once they're
towards us we have our [ __ ] together we
have a strategy we have tools now
there's an actual reason Beyond just
well we have ideas
so it's it's to work synchronistically
around the the local strategy but you
would be much more selective and who
kind of gets backing to run at the state
level is that accurate
I mean in theory that's up to the state
level but if I had to suggest I would
say yeah you're going to need a strong
messenger you're going to need somebody
with Charisma you're going to need
somebody who is who has some gravitas to
them maybe it may be a business owner or
somebody who people can respect and and
take seriously when they put this
message forward because again we're not
winning the race
what we're not so we can't compel people
on on that those grounds we have to
compel them on different grounds at that
level of race
so I mean uh uh the the in the past
midterms there was the kind of the the
race that got the most attention was in
Georgia because the candidate there
Chase Oliver uh forced a runoff
um what was your and and I talked to
chase Oliver a little bit before this I
see he's he's watching as well we might
bring up a couple of his comments
um he said he didn't really get a lot of
backing from the national uh LP uh until
he was kind of already making a splash
what was your evaluation of the kind of
campaign Chase ran is that the sort of
thing you would want to see in the
future I think he had some great moments
in the debates you know I think when
he's pointing out they don't read the
bills what he's trying to tap into there
is that these people don't have your
interests at heart they're not
representing you they're not serving you
and and I don't know if he would word it
this way but that's essentially a
populist message
um you know uh tapping into how the
little guy is being screwed over by the
big guy and I think that's great
um and and I actually publicly you know
congratulated him on his uh getting the
runoff and getting the attention from
stuff like that so I I do think that we
need to go in that direction I do think
populism is something that and that we
do need to employ I don't think populism
is is uh I think it's a tool it's not an
end of itself you know there's a reason
why Bernie Sanders who is on the
political uh left is a populist but also
so is Trump like populism isn't isn't
something in in and of itself Ron Paul
I thought I thought he employed a
Libertarian populist message yeah I
think and the FED is very populist it's
it's you're the little guy maybe you're
of modest means maybe you're you know
concerned about how you're going to
afford the groceries next week and
that's all being screwed up by this
banking Elite that doesn't have your
interest at heart I think we have to
push a little bit on the populist issue
in relation to chase uh Oliver's
campaign too what was different about
him is that he also pushed for uh very
strongly for uh kind of protection of
minority right rights whether they're
ethnic or sexual or racial minorities
which Cuts against the populist message
was that a big part of his appeal as
well
it's hard to say it's certainly
libertarian right because it's like hey
you know we're all individuals and we
get to kind of live how we want as long
as we're not uh you know really getting
in the face of other people
um and then uh just let me add one
little bit of context here because I
have some of the I have some of the
results from that Georgia Race So up on
the top there you see Chase Oliver kind
of that he's the one that covered the
spread there got about 81 000 uh running
for uh Senate then in the governor's
race there was Shane Hazel who I think
you would agree is more the mises caucus
mold candidates he's actually mentioned
in the decentralized uh decentralized
Revolution document and forced to run
off uh two years ago two years ago it
was actually in a very similar situation
and so he got about 28 000 and then the
lieutenant governor uh Ryan Graham
candidate got about 85 000.
um what do that those results mean you
know if any thing to you in in the
context of Nick's question so again I I
put this in the article and this might
be one of those hard pills for people to
swallow I honest to God am starting to
truly believe that our res our vote
results at this level of race is not
primarily driven by our own I don't
think we have the level of control over
the vote totals that we get at this
level of races we might like to think
um because you know Shane forced the
runoff he's a different style of
messaging than than Chase so like how do
you account for that in just two years
you know fundamentally we're arguing the
difference between one percent or three
percent which again in the long term
you're not building political capital
what's the real difference here
um I'm a you know reach the remnant guy
if if you reach one percent or three
percent electorally that doesn't matter
but if a thousand of those people really
get it and then come in that's what
matters so can I ask I would judge the
results off of something like that yeah
so uh that goes to Chase has a put a
question in our comment section saying
how do we get our name out there if
we're not if we aren't competing in the
highest profile races higher profile is
meant to help down ballot so I mean in a
way aren't you making an argument that
um you know you're going to reach the
remnant or you have a bigger chance of
reaching the remnant not just in Georgia
but across the country
um if you end up becoming a spoiler
yeah I don't mind being a spoiler and
and I think when those opportunities
come up yeah we have to narratively run
with that as okay we're a political
threat and I'm not suggesting that we
don't compete I mean we're talking
exactly you would said yourself about
how I'm we're not abandoning that what
I'm saying is that the reality is we're
not competitive we might be in the race
but we're not competitive and people
know that like nobody nobody is fooled
by this and thinks I think the
Libertarians got a real chance this year
I could see all these libertarian
elected State House members like we this
is one of the areas where we gotta get
real about ourselves and figure out
what's causing people to vote for this
level of race and tap into that because
if we don't have control of it then
maybe it's just discuss you know let me
let me bring up one other question here
from Chase well we're talking about him
and also the state level issue
um he mentions nationally we had the
frontier project that helped us elect
our first state legislator in a in a
generation that was in Wyoming I believe
uh Marshall art I think was his name and
yep uh he did not win re-election
um some libertarian party regulars see
that as as a big failure because you
know this is the one state legislator uh
that that we hadn't that the libertarian
party had in the whole country and now
with this new strategy kind of that the
wind has been taken out of those sales
is that because well first of all first
of all the mises pack had given
thousands of dollars to uh the frontier
project I appreciate their use of data
and their use of targeting to be as
realistic as possible at that level of
race so we had given thousands of
dollars to the frontier project directly
and we had also I feel bad I forget her
name the other woman that ran in Wyoming
that lost by a tiny bit we donated to
her directly as well
um however uh he did not win re-election
uh and and he won that race when it was
him versus a Democrat and then when the
Republicans put somebody up for the
first time in something like 15 20 years
he got got he lost and lost by a wide
margin despite the fact that he was
already elected and had that kind of
name recognition so again I just don't
think that we have the trust at that
level of race and we have got to get
serious and real with ourselves about
building from the ground up we have to
there's no narrative around us what is
that what is the the grand narrative
from people who are not already
Libertarians about Libertarians that's
up to us to craft in their minds because
we haven't done it
what should it be
so I I kind of made a post about this in
my opinion the the most basic way of
describing it is I would say that we
don't have any political voice in this
country that is about free markets about
uh the individual about uh Free Speech
property and all of these these uh kind
of core to our founding ideas we have
two flavors of progressivism
progressivism in this context meaning uh
people who think that the state can
solve problems and and make you a better
person in some sense you know you have
left progressives that think they can
make you more equal and less bigoted
you've got right progressives that think
they can make you more response that
they can make you more responsible and
and uh more moral
um and meanwhile the whole Paradigm the
entire Overton window as touched in that
is Progressive and so we have to
challenge that so can I ask I mean I I
agree with that but I already agree you
know I'm a Libertarian so like you know
the Republican party doesn't agree with
that and the Republican party has you
know effectively 50 market share uh
along with 50 for the Democrats they
we're not aggressives if you ask you
know Marjorie Taylor if you ask Donald
Trump if you asked Lauren bobert if you
ask the you know the members of the
Republican Party who just uh you know
the the rump group that essentially
forced Kevin McCarthy to do their
bidding if he were to become speaker
they're not they're not defining
themselves as Progressive and nobody in
the mainstream media is uh defining them
as Progressive the only people who are
are are Libertarians and that that
includes everybody from the Cato
Institute to reason to uh the mises
caucus to The mises Institute to the lp
um how you know how do you measure the
effectiveness not of what you're saying
or the internal consistency but how will
you see it actually changing people's
minds
we have to connect the dots because at
the end of the day we have to tell the
truth that's what has to be at the core
of it it can't just be ideology for
ideology's sake we have to tell the
truth and if the truth is that they're a
flavor of progressivism then we have to
run with that so then the question is
how do we connect the dots and and I
think you have to hit both sides from
different ways I mean yes you have to
hit the left from the left and hit the
right from the right but even deeper
than that I would argue that the the
left side of the Paradigm opposes
libertarianism on what you might call a
first principle basis I I think they
they actually oppose in large part
property rights and they they agree with
the collective over the individual the
problem with the right side of it is
that they're full of [ __ ] they they
claim to be for Liberty in some sense
and Liberty principles but then they're
protectionists and then they you know
they want their Trump checks and you
know all of this so we've got to hit
them on their own terms and connect the
dots while politically building the
trust to make the to to be able to open
that conversation but it all comes
together in a significant way I mean
you're your political strategy is not
about the grand narrative your political
strategy is going into towns you know
towns and cities at the at the council
level at the sub-county level and saying
hey you know we we're not Republicans Or
democrats we're not team red or team
blue here what we are is we have a
problem with crime we have a problem
with garbage collection we have a
problem with uh really shitty zoning uh
with onerous drug uh you know drug laws
and things like that and we're going to
elect people who are Liberty who happen
to be libertarian but you you democrat
you Republican will want to work with in
order to make your little town better
yeah I would say that's the building
political Capital part of the strategy
you do that's the other reason why you
have to have your statewide's and your
president you do have to have somebody
to kind of craft that grand narrative
because that's going to reach the
remnant but once you reach that Remnant
and they come in you gotta funnel it
into something that's actually viable
otherwise they're going to burn out
they're going to not see the point of
all of this and then they're going to
leave and either go apolitical or go
back to one of these other parties or
whatever so like we have to excite
people about the ideas and then with
that excitement drive them down into
viable activity in the long term
um I'm going to bring up a couple
comments here that I think will allow us
to dig a little bit more into something
you mentioned about progressives versus
the rights and you know uh
the likelihood that Libertarians are
going to reach one one side or another
I'm going to hit you with a little bit
of sugar and then something a little
bitter after that first this is uh David
versus Goliath who says the the lpmc is
the best thing to happen to the
libertarian party since David Nolan's
living room
um then we've got someone named the
mechanic is here saying the mises caucus
is purely conservative scum who oppose
everything that libertarianism is about
so quite a bit of polarization and
opinion here and
with regard to you know the charge that
you are really a bunch of conservatives
you're a bunch of uh right Wingers
um is that
is is that how accurate is that because
you do definitely say that you know the
progressives are the problem
um but do you have a fundamental
critique of kind of what's ascended on
the right the the right like what I'll
call the national conservatives the NAT
con that's what so party I is there a
problem with that or are you trying to
actually
uh draw from that and say we are
actually the more right-wing party than
the Republicans are well we have to draw
from wherever we can but as far as like
the political right I actually think
call it what you want call it the
dissident right call it the new Amer or
the the America first right I think
that's who we have to be having the
arguments with primarily right now I
think we're in competition with the
right in a way that we're not with the
left and again it goes back to this
point where the left is basically
already run the culture War they've
already done their War March through the
institutions they're already you know
bombarding us from Hollywood and pop
meet and pop culture and all all of this
stuff they've already won that so then
the question is what do we do about that
and we are in competition with this new
writer whatever you want to call call it
up to on how to push back with that so I
actually think we have to open up the
debates and the arguments and the fights
with the right in in higher priority
because again I think they're they are
trying to speak our language they're
trying to say that we're Liberty people
but we know that you know they're
protectionist we know that they uh have
not pin code on war and and all these
other things so we've got to do battle
with them to reclaim the narrative on
what to do with the fact that the
culture War has already been won whereas
with the left
that's a lot easier for for us to be
working against because again I think
they oppose us on a first principle
basis I think they oppose us on property
rights they're not really making that
argument the right is and that's why we
have to kind of do narrative battle with
them I think in in a way that we don't
with the left okay but what about what
you said earlier about the rights uh
assumption that the state is going to
enforce morality because that really
seems to be what's heating up now
um you know if in the broad what we call
culture wars like it's about
um you know how far should a governor or
a mayor go in kind of trying to advance
a certain view of uh morality where
does the mesos caucus
um fall on that and like what what uh
like how does it see the libertarian
party
um you know aligning in those cases I
think we need organic leaders again
leaders of competence not political so
no one's saying like uh you know take
the uh uh the sex surgery stuff for kids
you know like we need to have our own
leaders who are outside of politics that
we Elevate who have a strong voice and
can speak from a place of strength you
don't have to be a conservative to see a
problem with the the trans kids issue
and and you know sex surgeries for for
kids who aren't even allowed to join the
military and this kind of thing but is
anyone saying that oh the state is the
proper role for what is or is not moral
no and again I think this is something
where where Libertarians kind of blur
lines a little bit we we tend to take
libertarianism and make it out to be a
full-scale worldview when it's not it's
a political and legal Theory and there's
a lot of aspects of life that are
outside of those things that we have
free reign to operate in so we got to be
on on the right side of that I think we
do have to pitch a better story that
that uh makes a stronger Society one
great responsibility basically I guess
so from I and I think this is going to
what Zach was talking about in some of
the uh the comments it you know if you
want a politician who is saying no to
and and you know uh to uh uh sex
reassignment surgery for gender
reassignment surgery for minors you've
already got that that's what the
Republican party is you know they're
going Whole Hog on that so how does that
uh in somebody like Ron DeSantis who
seems to be conservative who seems to be
you know he he does say that he wants
the state to be an instrument of moral
instruction
um but he's also not a progressive he's
not a conservative like I'm trying to
get a sense of how how do you how do you
separate from somebody like that from a
Muse's caucus point of view well I think
what's happening within libertarian
circles right now is you kind of have
this Narrative of you know there's a
conversation that's happening where like
traditionally we'll say the left and the
right are the exact same thing and right
now the left is dominating so that is
have to go has to go by the wayside and
and you know we have to deal with what's
in front of us and the left is clearly
worse and on one hand I can see where
they're coming from like because frankly
the right is better than the left right
now in terms of the culture War
and and like I said in the document
um that's really the only thing that's
separating the political parties anymore
now that doesn't mean that Libertarians
ought to Advocate government intrusion
into the culture War but I think again
what is the proper role for things to
engage for people to engage in the
culture War I think it's example I think
it's leadership I think it's taking
responsibility I think it's the same
thing that we ought to be doing with
foreign policy where we can we can offer
to uh diplomacy we can offer advice we
can live the best that we can we can
take responsibility for ourselves and
and encourage that throughout Society
so I I don't what's that yeah well I
guess what what I was also trying to get
at is that is there a role for the
libertarian party to offer a you know
you say that um you know there's no kind
of cultural uh or let's say uh you know
libertarianism is not about dictating
what kind of someone's personal morality
is so there can be conservative
Libertarians there can be more
Progressive uh or socially liberal I
guess Libertarians but it really comes
down to what is the role of the state in
um enforcing morality and you know the
the the the kind of thrust of the
libertarian party now is um going
against wokeness right and so is but is
there a
a line that
um the libertarian party can draw or a
critique that the libertarian party can
make of the right on this because
um you know Nick brought up DeSantis
before and DeSantis is very aggressively
going into educational institutions and
kind of dictating you know what is
proper and improper to be taught and so
at both the K-12 any attempted at the uh
at higher education I mean he didn't
just attempt it at higher education it
is uh happening in in higher education
it's being challenged uh in the courts
now but
um like is there a hard line that uh the
libertarian party should be drawing
there and saying like yeah maybe uh a
lot of us are against some of these
excesses or we think that you know
surgery for minors is wrong but there is
a line that can be crossed in terms of
the State trying to enforce a
conservative
world view yeah but I don't I don't see
them advocating the state on things
outside of violence
you know like I I don't see them that I
mean even I think even most anarchists
would say that within political reality
it's okay to default to minicism in in
Practical reality you know and and again
this boils down to what does practical
reality look like for Libertarians if we
were engaged in it so like let me give
you a thought experiment as a
hypothetical let's say somehow you had
Libertarians uh enough Libertarians in
Congress right where you know there's
enough of us to influence policy but we
can't abolish the Department of
Education you know we can't get that
full separation of church and state and
a bill comes up that says hey we're
either going to have economics in one
lesson in the schools or we're going to
have some critical race Theory Book are
you are you doing a no vote
are you doing a present why would I I'm
voting for economic huh yeah I I don't
understand though uh that question I
mean that's a great thought experiment
and everything but what it comes down to
is like we are advocating for I would
assume a school system where individuals
have maximum choice to go to school
right what I'm right you always aim for
that you always agitate towards that you
always argue to that no does that mean
in a Florida context you are comfortable
with the state saying here is a list of
ideas and Concepts that are absolutely
forbidden to be taught in public schools
I'm saying if I can't get the ideal I
will take better I know but is that the
better because that's the real life
situation now where in Florida in a
number of other states you have
Governors saying these Concepts these
lists of words uh sometimes particular
books cannot be taught in public schools
um well that's that's what a curriculum
is a curriculum is we're teaching these
books and nothing else you know what I
mean so like making it illegal no it's
not necessarily nothing else I'm saying
like under under desantis's law even
Charter Schools would not be allowed to
do you know to to participate oh no no
no I I a wholesale yeah no wholesale
like that no
um but again if I was if I was in like
uh
a board or whatever that decided
curriculum and I couldn't get the full
abolition of of state and education then
yeah I'm going for economics
I accept that uh Michael and like you
know it's you're kind of asking like if
your choices between Florida or
California schools like what are you
going to do because they're both kind of
being shaped by the government and I
mean I've made my choice but uh at the
same time I do think there's value in
the libertarian party being the party
that reframes these things and says this
is not really the correct uh lens I
agree with it looking at things through
like uh
all uh like forced into a
one-size-fits-all system yeah or or two
I mean aren't we or aren't you by
participating in the culture where the
libertarian party saying we're going
after wokeness wokeness is the is the
enemy this is a culture War phenomenon I
mean you know what if they gave a
culture War and the libertarian party or
the music caucus to didn't come you know
and instead of playing that game where
it's easy to be mistaken for you know if
the old joke was that uh Libertarians
were Republicans who smoked pot now it's
maybe Libertarians or Republicans who do
shrooms uh but you know like you know
where you know who is talking about
actually you know balancing the budget
who was talking about policy as opposed
to these hot button issues and it seems
in many ways the mises caucus takeover
of the libertarian party has coincided
with saying you know what we're you know
we're not talking about abortion because
it's too complicated we're not talking
about this we're not talking about that
but like you've actually abdicated some
policy questions there and so again I
think I think I think the role of the lp
is you have to agitate and argue towards
the ideal
and and so I think we have done a lot on
War I mean the parties on several issues
I think they are talking about inflation
they are talking about the FED they are
talking about war the threat Coalition
anti-war rally at uh and people can go
to rage against war.com and check that
out
um but um so I think they are doing that
but I think peppered into that we have
to find our lanes to get into the the
Zeitgeist essentially we have and so I
think the hot button issues is how you
can do that how do we enter the
conversation if they're not inviting us
to the conversation we have to force our
idea thank you I I appreciate that uh
clarification and I guess but then my
question is if you enter the trans
debates which are you know so overheated
for the number of people are affected by
it and and the size like I I know of
virtually no people who say that um you
know the state or you know that that
chill underage children should have
absolute right to gender reassignment
surgery against their parents wishes but
if you're entering these debate States
in on the team of somebody who's already
kind of owns that issue I think you risk
confusing uh the libertarian identity
with a republican identity in this case
right but again we have to be
truth-based you know what if it's both
true that the the political right is is
narratively better on this issue and
also true that Biden ended the war in
Afghanistan in in foreign policy that
makes him better than Trump
like what what if this is true
yeah what about
um I mean yeah yeah I think um just to
make a little bit of a a pivot here to
bring it back to um the policies uh that
that are outlined in this document as a
little bit of a palette cleanser I want
to play this Montage of clips from uh
Harry Brown who was the 1996 and 2000 uh
libertarian candidate for president and
he's somebody uh Joe Jorgensen was his
VP in Oregon and
um he's mentioned in the music this
document that we're discussing today so
let me just play these this Montage from
Harry Brown and then get you to talk a
little bit about what uh you think uh
the the new libertarian party might
learn from the old libertarian party
pardoned everyone who has been found
guilty of a federal non-violent gun
control offense I will pardon everyone
who has been found guilty on a federal
tax evasion charge I will pardon anyone
else who has been convicted of any kind
of victimless crime by the federal
government
I will end Federal affirmative action
immediate
the elimination that the federal
government is engaged in I will bring to
an end immediately all asset forfeiture
cases and I will take immediate steps to
try to apply restitution to anyone who
has been victimized by the federal
government in the past as
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces I
will immediately bring all American
troops back home to America where they
belong
foreign
[Applause]
I will personally go through and get rid
of all the regulations that run up the
price of all the things we buy and hold
down the wages we earn and then
I will break for lunch
[Applause]
okay so what uh what lessons are you
taking from the days of Harry Brown
so I think the biggest appeal at least
to me personally is that he's kind of a
radical in a suit
like that's and it's the same thing with
Ron Paul he's kind of a radical in a
suit
um and and I think there's been
I don't know like I think there's been a
conflation when it comes to this whole
radical versus pragmatic debate that
radical necessarily means making a
spectacle for the sake of the spectacle
um and and I don't think that's right I
think you can be a radical in a suit and
I think that's how it kind of punches
the hardest and
so I I hear that that's I think I see
that in his presentation I hear him
speaking to to you know pure first
principles in in his Solutions so I I
think those are two you know really
strong things for him and I also think
at the time the libertarian party itself
like the leadership of the party itself
was engaged in way better strategy you
know they were engaged in data sharing
with uh with uh Harry Brown they were
they were buying data from other uh
organizations as you know the Harry
Brown thing was going on so they had
this high peak of energy around Harry
Brown they were getting data and then
using him as the lightning rod to excite
people kind of like what I'm saying to
funnel and and then from there I don't
think they had like the ground game for
the local strategy that I'm going to try
to use to keep people in the long term
but I think those are all very strong
points in his favor
a little bit of data there
um you know you've mentioned in the
documents and this this is backed up by
this data that you see this spike in the
libertarian party donors
um back that spike is during the Harry
Brown years of 1996 through 2000 so that
was kind of the high point of the donor
numbers electorally Harry Brown uh did
not do particularly well compared to
importantly yeah yes what do you think
explains the disconnect Michael
electorally same thing with Ron Paul
yeah that uh you know uh you know very
first principle oriented you know
radical in a suit
um why didn't they pull better numbers
uh electorally
my theory is that again I don't think
our our uh outcomes at that level are
primarily driven by our own efforts I
think they are driven by how disgusted
people are with the status quo you know
one way or the other and they just can't
take it anymore and I think we have a
much higher level of disgust with
politics in general and politicians in
general uh today than we did back then I
don't think that's really up for debate
uh yeah I mean it's also though in 96 I
mean uh there was a huge level of
disaffectation between Bill Clinton and
uh Bob Dole I mean nobody was excited
about that race and uh Clinton wasn't
even able to win 50 percent of the vote
against the weakest Republican you've
been going downhill for a long time I
know
uh no and and in 2000 there was a
palpable sense of contempt for Al Gore
as well as for George Bush which also
led to neither candidate winning 50
um it's uh I'm just curious of yeah so
there's basically there's a lot of your
there's a lot of complicated factors
both at the Electoral level you could
also argue at the fact that there was
that Spike during the Harry Brown years
could have had to do with these external
factors and not as much to do with Harry
Brown because as Nick just mentioned you
know Ron Paul ran as a candidate in 1988
pretty uh hardcore radical guy uh and
get the Spike did not come until later I
mean obviously the end of the end of the
Cold War the rise of the internet uh you
know a uh the uh economy taking off in
the second half of the 90s all changed
things I mean the the the broader
cultural context for libertarianism
exploded in the 90s for a lot of
different reasons including uh the rise
to uh you know kind of uh visibility of
of the Cato Institute and reason we saw
exponential growth particularly online
as the decade unwell so but so we've
talked you know local state now what is
the me the project decentralization uh
strategy or decentralized revolution
strategy for the net at the national
level
it's it's basically just a macro version
of what I've already said about the
state level that is that is our biggest
megaphone opportunity that is our
biggest opportunity to attract people uh
and to to get ourselves into the
conversation and hopefully expanding
that Overton window because like again
if if I'm right if my theory is right
and then and people aren't voting for
Libertarians necessarily because of the
candidate itself it's not necessary it's
it's more about who you attract more
than how many you attract so we want
what we want is people coming in on the
right basis and with the right attitude
and with the right level of motivation
to actually become members and do this
work in the long term by joining our
community
so it's it's the same thing it's getting
as much media attention as possible but
again I think the term media is a little
bit different today than than you know
yeah very different Yeah you mentioned
that uh in the document
um hold on I gotta find that uh there's
something about oh yeah you mentioned
that the there's a media landscape that
actually now favors a radical
decentralized approach where
Libertarians can have a voice and then
you talk about all the podcasters out
there
um someone like Dave Smith you know goes
on The Joe Rogan Experience gets
millions of views on a clip where he's
you know talking about the Ukraine
intervention
um how far do you think that ultimately
can be pushed in terms of uh translating
into electoral success because yeah I
mean Joe Rogan Experience is is huge
um on the other hand how many Joe Rogan
listeners are ultimately going to go and
you know vote how many how many CNN
listeners are going to to go and take up
calls with us I mean what media if Joe
Rogan isn't the fertile environment or
one one example of the referral
environment sure who who exactly is the
big whale that we're chasing otherwise
maybe it's not yeah I mean maybe it's
not media driven I mean that's part of
the question right but again we have to
we have to have our grand narrative out
there we have to have our grand
narrative out there so to kind of just
put context like numbers context you
know we can sit here and say well maybe
Joe Rogan's audience is this or that
last time uh I looked maybe six months
ago
um Tucker Carlson was the biggest news
show on cable television at about 3.3
million viewers per episode Joe Rogan 12
or 13 million he's three to four times
bigger than the biggest new show and and
again this is all still emerging we
don't have a podcast that's regular hit
regularly hitting 50 million downloads
the Paradigm is still shifting that's
gonna happen this is all still emergent
you know uh uh Greg Gutfeld 2.2 million
beating all of the the late night comedy
shows
um and yet that's nothing I mean that's
probably Tim Poole probably gets more
than that let alone all this other
Patchwork of people who have a million
subscribers here 900 000 subscribers
there you know so it there's a lot there
yeah I I mean I I basically agree with
you that uh it's the the kind of
fracturing media landscape is probably a
good thing for Libertarians that's a
great thing other Outsiders and there's
a lot of opportunities there uh by
pessimism there is that the the debates
still seem to be very important
um and that's been a big hurdle for the
libertarian party forever is getting
into those debates they spent a lot of
effort you know trying to get past that
threshold and you know just falling
short with the Gary Johnson campaign is
that even worth worrying about anymore
in your world are you saying that's just
kind of where I think we can get around
them I think we can get around them and
and because well two things one I have
no idea what the debates are even gonna
look like now because the Republicans
pull it out of the debate commission
that may be a good thing that maybe bad
thing I don't know what that is going to
mean for the debates honestly I don't
and and
um but I also think that when you have
this New Media Paradigm what happens
when Tim if if and when uh Tim Poole and
Joe Rogan and Jimmy Dore or something
come together and saying we're throwing
our own debates that's on the table
that's something that could
realistically happen you know and and I
mean I know in
2016 I forget it was 16 or 20.
um Trump at one point even said yeah
I'll come on Joe Rogan and debate now he
knew that I think it was 20 20. I think
I think it was uh bite and he knew Biden
wouldn't do it but the point of the
matter is that you have the the already
sitting president saying
I'll do that there's a demand for it if
I made the realistically when you're
talking about media exposure and you're
trying to appeal to a Remnant you're
looking for people who are going to
become party actors primarily at the
local level and win races where there
might be 50 votes cast in an entire
slate of of Elections year one so yeah
okay so I mean in a way uh you know
because it seems that most political
organizers will tell you that you know
the way that you win elections is by
having door knockers and people going
out into communities and turning out the
vote that way
um can I ask what have you uh is the Mrs
caucus working with groups like Young
Americans for liberty or other uh you
know groups that are I you know mostly
identified or affiliated with Republican
party candidates
um but are you know are they playing
ball with you or what what are you doing
about that ground game
um so we have run as libertarian.com and
so far we've recruited almost 300
candidates and campaign managers through
that uh through that funnel and we're
putting on trainings twice a month
online uh so far it's been a mix of
um
uh the Leadership Institute and our own
training modules
um so I mean we're we're utilizing
already established organizations that
have a history of doing this stuff as
well as starting to get ourselves off
the ground and get the community
training the community and and those
modules do things like this is how you
put out a press release this is uh how
you file for this this is you know how
you go you how you have a rally things I
mean basic nuts and bolts type stuff oh
yeah yeah no of course of course you
have to have door knockers I'm just
saying that I don't know if door
knockers at the presidential level is
going to overcome the distrust and the
knowledge that they're not going to win
but it might do it at the local level
where people are willing to take a
chance yeah I think uh you know since
we're bringing up the local level again
this might be a good moment to bring in
this clip uh this other clip that I
pulled from the decriminalized Denver
movement this was the initiative to uh
the successful initiative to
decriminalize magic mushrooms in Denver
and it's uh now been decriminalized
Statewide
but this is something you identify as a
kind of model that you want to uh
emulate uh so I want you to let I want
to play this clip and then
um just react and and tell me you know
what what this means uh from a political
strategy standpoint it's one of the
first two U.S states to legalize
recreational Cannabis sales which it did
by voter initiative in 2012 putting it
on the frontier of American drug policy
then and now this is the best place in
the country to do this right now Denver
and maybe the state of Colorado uh is in
in many ways at least with drug policy
embracing more of this libertarian
concept that you know as long as I'm not
causing harm to sell for others
um we should be we should have the
freedom to use whatever substances we
choose and put into our bodies whatever
we choose Denver's decriminalization
initiative makes the possession or use
of psilocybin the city's lowest law
enforcement priority and prohibits the
city from spending resources to impose
criminal penalties for the personal use
and personal possession of psilocybin
mushrooms by persons 21 years of age and
older and also establishes a panel to
review the effects of the change in law
it does not legalize commercial sales of
mushrooms leaving a potentially large
gray Market
Sovine says her experience in cannabis
legalization which progressed from
medical to recreational every state
that's legalized it convinced her that
decriminalization rather than
medicalization is actually the far more
radical and liberatory path to take
maybe we want to see doctors being able
to prescribe psilocybin but is that the
only way we want to be able to access it
should we still be going to jail and
having it be a criminal offense outside
of having a physician prescribe it for
you lawfully I think that the core
tenant and the reason why the campaign
became what it was today was because we
don't necessarily think that going
through that process necessarily means
access to all patients
yeah so I include that last clip because
an interesting aspect of the this law is
that it was sort of modeled on like
Sanctuary city laws where it's really
about telling
um that you know local law enforcement
saying we're not we're just not going to
prioritize this
um whatever the federal government or
the state laws are it's just not going
to be something we deal with
um and uh I wonder you know uh what is
that uh you know what what do you make
of that template and how can it be
applied in other Realms because I know
that that's something that you're
interested in I think so even with my
strategy like I said we've recruited 300
or ish candidates and campaign managers
we're just not at a political reality
yet where Libertarians are filling up
the ballot which means there's got
there's going to be places where there's
not Libertarians on the ballot where we
need to do something
um and I really think the issues is the
realm where we're going to create the
most trust and I think that is a good
example of that because Kevin who is the
guy in those clips is a good friend of
mine we got we got involved in that
effort and if you remember that effort
passed by the skin of its teeth the
Denver one specifically
um and and in fact they they pronounced
that it did not pass the day of the vote
and then the next day said oh it just
barely got over the top Kevin called me
after that and was like thank you man
like we got the libertarian party of
Colorado to endorse that effort you know
there was Libertarians on that effort
now there's trust now there's trust
there and I can have that conversation
and Kevin is going to be coming to one
of our take Human Action tour events and
and so again I think issues are probably
the fastest way that Libertarians can
get involved uh uh shift The Narrative
around an issue push something forward
that normal people want not necessarily
the political class and and
um build that trust and have the
conversation and I think Kevin over the
course of his experience has become more
libertarian as a result
yeah so I love that yeah yeah yeah and I
I I talked to Kevin before this and he
told me yeah he does he's he's a fan of
Michael Heiss and um that yeah you you
secured I guess the Oregon party
libertarian party uh endorsement of of
the initiative
um what what are you know uh when you
think about the local offices there's
very specific ones that you mentioned
like uh city council and Sheriff I think
there were maybe a couple others mayor
School Board mayor School Board what are
the components uh like what are the
powers that these have that you are
hoping that Libertarians elected at the
local level will be able to use
um to like you know immediately Advance
Liberty
so with with Denver and like that effort
they're a state that has ballot
initiatives available to them and not
every state does it's like 26 24 or
something like that so in those states
that don't have that you're going to
have to go the lobbying route and and
um
you know you can affect issues that way
but that's also getting elected as a
Libertarian to city council is how you
can do exactly what was done with that
ordinance just it's just a different
methodology of attaining it like you can
push back against your state laws you
can push back against federal laws and
and uh you know that is the Big Value
there is is their ability to nullify the
the out of control feds and you can do
it with all manner of things you know
like you can do it with essentially
anything that's not in article one and
section eight
um from from drugs to to guns to um to
immigration you know to uh even aspects
of monetary policy like you see out in
Missouri they're doing a state level
initiative to um essentially recognize
gold and silver as currency
um there's all kinds of things that we
can do it's just we've got to get real
about where we can do them and we're not
going to win federal office and do it
and but we can do it on a Town by Town
basis while building up our political
capital and our trust level with the
people at a ground at a Grassroots level
uh at the uh mises caucus website uh in
the issue campaigns that you mentioned
because you
rightly talking about how uh issues
oftentimes are places where a small
number of Libertarians or or any kind of
third-party or or a special interest
group can really make a big impact the
issue campaigns that are mentioned are
abolishing lockdowns decriminalizing
psychedelics and cannabis and keeping
guns free are there particular places
either in large cities or at the state
level that are on the you know that are
in your uh scope to actually start
moving on um I or you know so where is
the next uh Denver uh decriminalization
that you are actually targeting and
looking towards there's several methods
of figuring that out I mean can I tell
you Town X not off the top of my head
but what I can tell you is that again
it's like I said in our original
interview if you live in a blue town
like a very blue town and they are not
decriminalized
we're at a point right now where people
can have their opinions on what happened
with the Brittany grinder thing oh they
should have done it they shouldn't have
done it none of that matters in my
opinion what matters is the fact that
they did it gives us as Libertarians the
opportunity to go and say you to Blue
towns and say your president said that
he wanted to Pardon uh federal marijuana
convicts and and brought this chick home
why are our people in jail here you know
and and kind of torque them hit the left
from the left so I think we have to
basically go to the blue towns hit them
with hit them on uh issues of overlap
that we have with them and do the same
thing on the right and I would Target
the reddest towns and The Bluest towns
respectively to start with and move down
from there depending on how many people
you have in a given town
I want to go just talk a little bit
about uh results and what uh success
would look like and then maybe turn to
some of the questions because some some
interesting questions have come in from
the audience
um and if you have any other questions
everyone who's watching now would be a
great time to throw some more in
um but you know you said at the end of
that interview with Nick something like
buy our fruits you'll know us so you're
saying like just look at what happens
and and you'll see and you know it's
it's still early on but I want to give
everyone context of what has happened
since the Takeover these are this is
some data that we were going through
this is just the historical the historic
data of uh donors
um to the libertarian uh party over 10
years and the reason I'm pulling this up
is just to show an overall pattern you
see these spikes in election years
followed by a decline and then another
spike in in 2020 there and another
decline so that's kind of the historic
pattern that is to be expected now this
is a closer 12-month look at active
donors and the reason I'm talking about
active donors is because this is
something Michael has said is what we
should judge them by the the intensity
and size of the support for the party so
you see that there's a little bit of a
decline and then a spike that spike is
right after the Reno convention when the
uh mises caucus kind of took over
leadership of the party and then you see
this slow Decline and it's it's settled
down below the level before the takedown
so that that doesn't look uh great and
then we we talked a little bit about
um you know some of the the state seat
that was lost overall
um there's fewer Libertarians that are
holding elected office now than than
were before
uh these are numbers that we will all
link below uh in the show notes
um so what do you make of you know
what's transpired so far uh why what's
your explanation for that
um and when would be fair for us to kind
of Judge your your efforts and the
results of the Arena reset
so we're about seven months in and I
think you're you're seeing a big
reconstruction essentially you know
there's been turnover on the staff as
the the vision of the party has changed
um you know all that kind of stuff so
you know there was a big surge of people
after and the party also just posted a
financial report posting its first two
million dollar a year in the midterm
elections in like 20 years or something
like that so you know you can uh you can
do a lot of things with data
um I can tell you that I've been on the
phone all week with entrepreneurs and
with influencers who are coming our way
um and and saying you know we have
audiences uh we you know we have our own
businesses we have you know Community
respect and stuff like that and I want
to take up calls with you uh and take up
calls with the lp so I think I think
it's analogous to like Twitter you know
like musk came in bunch of employees
came out uh you know it looked like
there could be issues well now it's like
one of the top downloaded apps again and
people have a little bit more faith
although they got to free my boy Scott
um and you know people have more yeah
Scott Horton needs to be put back on
Twitter
um but um you know so I I think we're in
the middle of that reconstruction period
so as far to answer your question
um you know I I have always thought that
it would be expected that there might be
a short-term dip as that reconstruction
happens you know there are people who
are kind of been around in the move in a
while who have no idea what happened
still
um and so you know I would ask your
audience if you like what I'm saying go
to lp.org join join the party uh help
them out and uh
as far as when's Fair
23 is going to be our year one for
putting out the uh the political
strategy and then obviously 24 is going
to be dominated by the uh the
presidential race so stick with the uh
by your fruits uh you shall know us uh
line when's When's the first harvest
I think this anti-war rally I mean when
is the last time you saw the libertarian
party get out in the streets and get out
in the community so
um you know the you know if by the end
of the 2024 election cycle you have you
and the the mises caucus uh supervisor
you know kind of uh leadership of the
party hasn't significantly changed
things is it is it right to say okay you
you guys have failed
I would have to see the data okay
yeah I would have to see the data
um Nick do you have any other uh
questions before I turn to some of these
audience questions uh yeah let's run
through the questions and then let's
talk about the uh The Curious Case of uh
Dr uh Dr Ron Paul and Dr Rand Paul
um after that okay okay
um so this is a question that's
representative of a few that have come
in from Silver sword Studios question
for Michael do you think the rhetoric or
in your words strong messaging of the
mises caucus has effectively worked to
promote the broader libertarian movement
to what extent if so
so yeah I really do actually
uh sorry about that yeah I do um so
first of all in your first video where
we did our first interview at reason I
would encourage people to go to that
video and look at the comments the most
liked comments on that whole thing from
your guys's audience was this guy is
speaking to exactly why I wasn't in the
libertarian party I am hopeful I'm
encouraged I want to join and it's just
filled to the brim like of things like
that in there
um we have gained the party has not had
the support of the biggest voices of the
Liberty Movement the Tom Woods is the
Scott Hortons the you know the Dave
Smith prior to this you know and all of
that stuff we've brought them in I'm
telling you I'm I'm talking to a lot
more influencers and all the time now
and entrepreneurs who who are coming in
so I I think we have and I think it's
just going to be a matter of time for
you know that that's a play out and and
them to influence their audiences and
you know we've got a lot to do Maj
Torres at work uh hard at work
recruiting for the party you know
there's there's just a lot of this stuff
that's going on right now how you know
I'm looking at a January 6 post from the
lp uh national account and it's a shot
of Adam kinzinger and a couple of uh
cops who were involved in the January 6
protest and it says grown men who cry
like little babies on national TV over a
protest shouldn't be rolling over you
this was sent to me by a couple of
high-profile Libertarians who were like
you know this this makes me want to
leave the libertarian movement not the
party
um I mean how do you assess that kind of
uh backlash or you know I think about
um you know there's one thing I think we
all agree
um I mean certainly on this call that
the United States should not be involved
in Ukraine uh certainly not in any kind
of direct military capacity but even you
know giving Aid and things like that
um how does making a statement saying
the U.S should not be involved in
Ukraine can part with a lot of LP
National and mises caucus are affiliated
people who are like zelenski is a
Welfare Queen zolenski is a Neo-Nazi
zelenski is this like do you ever like
how do you how do you work to discipline
your messaging so that you are not like
needlessly alienating people who are who
agree with you uh and they might be that
you know January 6 is full of [ __ ]
um but then it's another thing to kind
of make a message that is mocking you
know people who are you know serious in
their in their comportment and whatnot
so lenski came into our country waved
his country's flags and got our
politicians to give him billions of
dollars and then is seen on play on on
luxurious votes and and all of this
stuff right uh and he also was at first
willing to negotiate you know a
ceasefire and allowed himself to be
turned by Boris Johnson so I don't think
zalenci what are we supposed to Revere
zielinski no I'm not saying we're
supposed to reverse zelenski if Ukraine
if the internal politics or the external
politics of Ukraine don't matter to us
why foreground zielinski as opposed to
Putin
why not foreground Putin in exactly the
same terms you're talking about and this
is where I'm asking as as a strategy
issue I'm not asking why you would
legitimate it or why you would uh you
know uh rationalize it but it's like you
know for the same reason that like you
know I mean you know that that's the
question to me because American because
American policy has nothing to do with
Putin it isn't it isn't aiding him we
have no control over that but we do have
control in our ability to fund this war
to keep uh having people die so that
Ukraine can be used in this uh uh
geopolitical agenda to weaken Russia for
for the strength of of globalism like in
all this crap like that's the only thing
that we have control over what am I
going to do shake my fist to say Putin
back off I mean yeah in in principle you
should maybe maybe it's that the proper
you know because again the Republican
party or or certain aspects of the
Republican Party are already attacking
zelenski
yeah and and he did that on on behalf of
Western geopolitical interests
well I mean but again my question is the
strategy of you're trying to appeal to
Americans right who who are going to
join the libertarian movement and I the
question was how do you go from how do
you not needlessly alienate people who
would be like you know what we shouldn't
be involved in Ukraine but I'm not sure
that I want to be involved with people
who personalize this and talk about you
know zielinski as a Neo-Nazi zielinski
is this or that any more than they find
it reprehensible when people say Russia
is not all bad but then they actually
you know Embrace Putin that's the last
gasp of but it's not it's not what it's
not like it's new for America to be
funding really [ __ ] up groups I mean
how many terrorist groups in the Middle
East did we fund and train you know or
what are we supposed to just ignore that
we're doing this righteous Crusade and
the narrative is that uh uh zelinski is
this freedom fighter and he's shutting
down religions and all of this stuff
like as again that's what our policy is
tied up in our policy is not title
there's kind of we're kind of limited in
what we can do now yeah well the issue
that I've seen with uh some of the
messaging around foreign policy is the
the shift that has happened
um because the previous libertarian
party was also pretty uh strictly
non-interventional principled
non-interventionists but there would be
expressions of you know solidarity with
people who are you know fighting for
their freedom whether it's in Hong Kong
or
um trying to keep their Liberties in
Taiwan or you you know Russia did invade
Ukraine and try to March all the way to
Kiev
um so the idea that um there you can be
against an intervention but still have
empathy for the people who are you know
fighting for their lives and their
Liberty that seems to have been lost in
the mix to some degree is that fair is
that a fair reading I don't think so I
mean because I think it's pretty
empathetic where where are people where
are the mises caucus where the mises
caucus tweets supporting the people of
Ukraine in for their self uh
determination
I think by getting us out of there it is
that because I think this war would have
been ended at this point if we weren't
pumping this money I think a lot less
people would be dying if we weren't
keeping it going so that they could have
this geopolitical agenda to weaken
Russia at the expense of all these
Ukrainian lives what's more empathetic
than that
uh you know what is like a tweet that
would say we you know the the people of
Ukraine have a right to fight for their
own uh you know uh lives uh but not with
US dollars as opposed to you know the
the types of Twitter I mean right but
not but again what caused like yes he
invaded and that is totally [ __ ] up so
but at the same time at the same time we
have to look at all the provocations and
all the nuances my question is not about
the specific stuff and it's also like at
the lp Angela McArdle you may have said
something like this that to you know to
show support or solidarity with the
people of Hong Kong or or the people of
Taiwan is to engage in CIA talking
points my question is that kind of
rhetoric does that do you are you
comfortable or are you confident that
that will yield more supporters in
America than it will alienate again I
think we have to tell the truth and we
have to look for the right people so I
don't know what it means to needlessly
divide because the I'm I'm a big
proponent of the fact and it is a fact
that the power of the state that we talk
about is that if you say Taiwan should
not be invaded by China then you're
you're as a dupe of the CIA I mean this
yeah I wouldn't go that yeah I wouldn't
go that far but what I would say is that
the nature of the power that is exerted
over us well yes at root is is raw power
we're talking about hang on let me
finish one I would say the number one
method of control that that is exerted
over us is psychological and therefore
narrative and then they use the fact
that we are social animals to then
enforce that narrative so they can do
whatever they want and it's okay and
nobody pushes back and we have to be
very careful about their use of language
and recognizing these these patterns and
push back against that that's the extent
to which we have like one of the major
ways that we have to be involved in the
culture war is how language is being
used as neologisms to push their agenda
and that's
National border Integrity of Ukraine is
ultimately to be doing class Schwab's
bidding
I mean and I I you know what we do we
don't need to go on I'm just saying
though that this you know a lot of
people raise questions and I think it's
legitimate to say like you know the
rhetoric that you're employing in order
to achieve these goals which which we
share certainly in the in the case of
Ukraine
um you know how do you factor in you
know and it's not about truth because
we're talking about rhetoric and
narrative here you know how do you how
do you count up how many people that
might bring in you know that are good
and how many people that might alienate
and that's bad
I think that question Cuts both ways how
do you do it because what because you
because well I know that I I mean I yeah
okay what I know is that since since the
the um takeover the social media
engagement has gone way up and that is
not that is not
a end in and of itself like I get that
like that has to be used to recruit
people but I'm telling you me personally
our social media is also way up and I'm
now getting more and more entrepreneurs
and and things like that that I've ever
had in my inbox wanting to talk to me my
days are filled with phone calls to
these people
figuring out you know okay because it's
one thing a lot of people want to call
you or they want to bend your ear but
it's going to be the number of party
members the number of donations right
and and the number of elected officials
right and I think there's still some
ways to go in terms of programs you know
what I mean like right now the party has
been inundated with basically cleaning
up the fires that were lit on the way
out so like what are the incentive
programs
you know I don't think we've gotten to
that yet yeah uh like membership
incentive programs what's the membership
recruitment Drive campaign I don't think
we've gotten to that yet you know these
things all do have to happen yeah
I lost this question but somebody was
asking uh oh here it is
um uh related Dylan Griffin how much
involvement does the misos caucus have
in controlling the social media content
of State Affiliates zero zero so that
that one uh problematic uh State
affiliate out there is not a a mises
caucus uh branded
affiliates
okay I mean the the people who became
the leadership there you know they were
our guys but again as I said in our
original interview
um while I might not agree with every
tweet I also think that it worked for
them that they tripled their membership
and I also think there's a way of
handling things you know people we're
all engaged in politics and I'm not
gonna sit here and flog people publicly
and then say Hey you know uh uh please
volunteer that's just not how it works
in a professional volunteer organization
um you know I think you talk to people
privately it's like you know putting out
tweets of you know Megan McCain crying
at her dad's funeral and joking about
that's just another example of kind of
this like weird lack of empathy that I
don't think uh like reflects well on
Libertarians as a whole everybody for
who
yes Megan McCain's losing her father I
mean as a human being that is I don't
have empathy for Megan McCain why should
I
because you're a human being Michael
yeah but again no but you're also you're
in political communication so if you
don't have sympathy how are we supposed
to express our rage at these problems
where is that where is the valve for
that yeah because I know I will say that
one is about the at the farthest Edge
that I'm willing to and that was our
conversation The Edge Lord conundrum
then right because you want to create a
world that's full of empathy and whatnot
but if you do it in that way
libertarianism is not about empathy per
se okay yeah it's not it's about
property rights now there's an element
of Tolerance but it's about property
rights and and free like free
association and and the right of you to
control your property
I say if you have you know say the most
outrageous thing that you want to say
that
uh right now that will help catapult
again because this is strategic
communication is strategic it's not
about truth per se like your your idea
is your philosophy your goals are rooted
in truth but is that the truth you know
that it's it's a good thing to mock
people who are crying at their father's
funeral I personally wouldn't have done
it yeah I personally wouldn't have done
it but I also get it because again where
is the expression of outrage at these
these War mongers these murderers in our
society how are we supposed to express
that politely uh you know what that
doesn't actually get to you know that I
doubt that that turned anybody into uh
less of a warmonger
um you know so I think it I think it
started a a conversation you know I I
think in start it did not start a
conversation about foreign policy it
started a conversation about the LP of
New Hampshire and the way it is
undercutting or affecting the ability of
Libertarians to gain more ground in
cultural discussions and political
discussions yeah I would say you know
empathy and just you know uh basic uh
human civility it does seem like an
important part of of politics and I
would argue empathy is an aspect of
libertarian philosophy as well but
that's a little far afield the the thing
that I was uh wanted to say about you
know the what Nick was Raising is
um this idea that
um you know there's there's the meme out
there of like I'm for the current thing
and what I worry about is that the
libertarian party is is turning into
there's a danger right yeah the inverse
of that at times of I'm I'm the against
the current thing like that is equally
purely reactionary absolutely yes it's a
reflective contrarianism that is not
it's just by definition not going to be
correct very often and it's going to
tarnish uh libertarian ideas because
libertarian ideas are you know meant to
analyze things for in a very uh specific
like reason based way instead of kind of
being reactive
um is that no I think that's right I
think we can't be purely reactionary
because then you can just be led around
the nose you got to be smarter than that
um but again that's that's one state
affiliate and they're running their
experiment and I think I think you know
we'll see what happens at their next
convention I think we'll see what
happens I mean I'm not talking about
that I'm talking about the the Ukraine
conversation that it kind of feels like
that it kind of feels like a lot of
people uh were feeling supportive of
Ukraine and so the libertarian party's
stance was well we have to be like as
anti-ukraine as possible some of that
has leaked in to like vaccine discourse
and so forth
um
it's it's concerning uh to people who
are trying to look at things uh and you
know reason through them on a
case-by-case basis
yeah I mean I I think uh we're speaking
to a lot of people that are furious at
the situation where you know our prices
are going up constantly and you know
they're angry and there has to be a a
positive channel for that anger I don't
think politics is characterized by
empathy right now
um and and I think that's why our job is
to abolish the state because who's the
one driving up the prices who's the one
spending our money on on these other
countries when we're falling apart you
know what I mean like it's you know
that's why I don't respect Megan McCain
and all these people who would destroy
our future I do think that uh what might
be reflected in this conversation is a
you know that actually a kind of
communication strategy aimed at the
remnant versus aimed at uh kind of uh
politically homeless people or something
like that that reflects to some degree
the mises caucus strategy versus a kind
of Reason magazine strategy
um but let's uh come we talk about Ron
Paul and Rand Paul because they come up
in the document
and I think that's a really interesting
you know kind of thing to talk about and
you know what sets your strategy apart
uh Michael from uh if not previous LP
things but it helps clarify it um can we
talk about Zach do you have the uh the
slide about
Rand Paul
um I I don't I don't have a well I'm
sorry so just yeah summarize what it is
Ron Paul is
um you know a republican but more he
kind of transcends the Republican party
in a way that Rand Paul doesn't
um you can kind of expand on that idea
Mike if if you would
sure well first of all I reject the the
notion that Ron Paul is a a republican
per se like I I think libertarianism is
a is a philosophy before it's uh a
political party and once we're getting
into political parties you're just kind
of talking strategy I think he at the
time that he was running and perhaps a
lesson that he learned from 1988 is is
that
um you get more attention if you're
running as a Republican and I think
that's been true for a long time and I
think that was kind of an animating
factor of why Libertarians should run as
Republican and we should try to take
over the Republican party but I also
think as we discussed earlier in this
conversation that the media Paradigm has
radically shifted to where in the long
term that is no longer serving our
interests
um you know I think it's hard to argue
that that Ron Paul
um didn't have an explosion in in people
reading bastiat and thinking about
libertarianism
um however
we now have the opportunity to get our
ideas on the tin pools and the Joe
Rogan's and the and the uh Lex friedmans
and all of this stuff to form our own
narrative about ourselves where we don't
have to kind of make these concessions
in order to try to have a shot at
getting attention and that's where I
think the kind of parable of Ron Paul
and Rand Paul comes in in my heart of
hearts I do think Ron Paul or I'm sorry
Rand Paul is a Libertarian I just think
he's playing a fundamentally different
game than than Ron Paul ever played but
I think because Ron Paul was always seen
as a Libertarian in uh in Republican
clothing
and and because he was able to Buck them
the way that he did that he was able to
have a cultural movement that that
transcended you know his inability to
pass uh bills whereas Rand Paul is
playing a political game and you'll see
even Republicans who who say well he's
he's like Trump you know I don't believe
he's like Trump but it doesn't that
doesn't matter at this point we're
talking perception and I think that's
because he has wrapped himself up in the
culture and The Narrative of the GOP and
that's what we now have to escape to
form our own language and Paradigm and
yeah
can you uh talk a little bit uh when we
we spoke uh last spring in Reno you said
that your politics come from Ron Paul
um just can you uh describe like how old
are you and was it the Ron Paul uh
campaign in 2008 that activated you into
politics or talk a little bit about how
he came to be you know he came on your
radar screen and kind of energized your
political worldview yeah so I'm uh 33
years old so I was about 18 19 at the
time of um you know that first race very
different world back then you know my
family had a computer in the living room
that we all shared with a dial-up
internet
um so you know I didn't know anybody I
didn't know what to do
um I didn't have you know uh these
groups and these these communities that
we have now is basically just your
parents are not super political or
anything like that I assume no no not
super political
um and um but uh essentially one of my
best friends showed me these clips of
Ron Paul and yeah that's that's what
activated me and I would say made me a
actual libertarian and started going
down that path
um and uh essentially 2012 came around
we decided we've got to do something and
I actually have videos of this where the
very first time I went out to the
Federal Reserve building in Philadelphia
just me and my friend and started
bullhorning the first amendment Center
about all these Federal Reserve talking
points that I picked up from Ron Paul
um and kept doing things like that and
then came on the radar of a meet-up
group an activist group in Philly called
Truth Freedom Prosperity about 40 of
them came out I found holy [ __ ] there
really is this underground world and
then I just never looked back
yeah what was it about Ron Paul that
appealed to you so strongly and I mean
you're not alone there's no question you
know Ron Paul I started a reason in uh
1993 and I'd say you know at that point
if you ask people why did they become a
Libertarian it was primarily uh you know
Iran Milton Friedman maybe Robert
Heinlein maybe reason a couple of other
things
um but you know there's no question
since 2008 on like Ron Paul is you know
one of the major feeders if not the
major feeder his courage it's it's as
simple as that it's his courage his his
willingness to Buck the Republican party
to rebut the to Buck the audience he
might be in front of and get booed
um to tell the truth I mean that I would
have to say that that's the core of it
um you know going into South Carolina
and making the the case for heroin is a
pretty tough sell
um and then to get them to cheer is a
freaking Miracle right and he also I
mean you're talking about that moment
when he was asked at a presidential
debate you know would you legalize
heroin and he said yes like I'm not
going to use it if it's legal would you
and it brought the house down he also
was willing in front of military or
military-leaning audiences to actually
critique American foreign policy in a
way that has really never been heard of
at the national level from an elected uh
Congressman really since like maybe the
30s but
right exactly all of that stuff I mean
of course I was animated by the freedom
philosophy and and the beauty of the
ideas and all of that stuff but on a
more personal deeper level Beyond
political philosophy the courage yeah at
the risk of reopening the uh past
conversation the Ron Paul the one thing
that is amazing about him as an
individual is like uh you know there are
people around him there's the
newsletters in the past Etc but when he
was on the national stage you know from
two you know really in the 21st century
on
you never heard he's the opposite of a
troll right he never spoke poorly of
anybody in front of him Etc and I mean
is there a is that part of his appeal
that he I think I I think so and I know
where you're going with that um but I
also think that we're in a different
time I also think that uh the
libertarian movement especially people
within the misosphere are much younger
and so I would I would say go back and
look at 1988 Ron Paul where you know he
basically said you know uh there was one
guy who was basically saying you know we
we have to have the government enforce
Morality In terms of drug use and I mean
he didn't use these words but he
essentially said well maybe the
government should put your fat ass on a
diet you know what I mean like and and
so you know I think uh we got Ron Paul
the grandfather and um maybe not Ron
Paul the the Beast athlete from back in
the day yeah that was from the Morton
Downey Jr show uh if anyone's gonna look
for that on YouTube which was like the
kind of like Forerunner to like Jerry
Springer in a way but with a slightly
more intellectual uh Edge to it I don't
think that especially when he said he
would puke on him that was very
intellectual going to say that uh yeah
Martin Eddie Jr and intellectualism have
never been uh seen in the same rooms but
uh and I'll also just point out very
quickly that uh Ron Paul also uh was
able to hit home runs in Congressional
baseball games while burdened by the uh
rainbow Astros uniform of the 70s and
early 80s
a different planet
um you also if I may um you know you you
had said you got your politics from Ron
Paul your philosophy from Jordan
Peterson
um what do you mean by that and uh you
know what what you take from Jordan
Peterson and or your personal
preferences somehow wrapped up in the
project of the of the you know mises
caucus
so what I what I mean by that is I think
it's important to set the table when it
comes to Jordan Peterson because I find
that people come into understanding
Jordan Peterson from all these different
angles you know like there might be
people who didn't follow him in 2017 who
came in on his comments of like oh this
fat chick on the cover of this magazine
is not beautiful you know what I mean
um but I I think a lot of people that
came into Jordan Peterson came in with
with nothing having to do with politics
at all
um I think they came in through his
Bible lectures
um that's certainly where I came in and
those Bible lectures are not political I
mean he might have the off comment here
about how you know if um this
philosopher said that uh religion is the
opiate of the masses communism is the
methamphetamine of the masses you know
he might have little things about that
that Herod Herod is obviously part he
would have been part of aoc's Posse
things like that things like that and
and um uh but I would say the core of of
if I had to give a bumper sticker
message for what Jordan Peterson's
cultural internationally cultural
phenomenon that around him from that
2016 to 2019 period was if I could put a
bumper sticker on that it would be
voluntarily adopt as much responsibility
as you can in your life and if you do
that that will imbue your life with the
meaning necessary to uh you know carry
yourself through the dark times and
those dark times will come as a matter
of uh you know human existence as a
matter of human existence so you like
the I mean his uh uh you know I mean his
uh interest in archetypes and in a kind
of yes
yes I I think essentially I think just
the same way that Ron Paul was this
figure that got all these young people
reading bastiod and mises and Hayek and
rothbard I think Jordan Peterson was the
same thing for for Carl Jung and Carl
Rogers and and souls nitchen and and
Nietzsche and all these different
thinkers that have a lot to say it's not
political per se but I do think that
there's overlap because what is Liberty
if not taking maximal responsibility for
our lives and and and I think there's a
beauty to that and I think the whole I I
think just as much as the state we have
a serious problem with with nihilism in
our culture and in our society and and
um we have gotten to fight back about
that how do you define nihilism
like hopelessness not seeing the meaning
in things thinking you know and and um
you know just thinking that there's no
purpose but people don't act that
premise out they act as if they're aimed
at a goal that's the whole point of
Human Action that we're goal oriented
and perhaps you could say that the
highest of all goals is a is divine
whether that exists as a supernatural
reality or not is irrelevant it's it's
the thing that guides us and and and
um basically we form uh an ideal of
ourselves that we would like to be and
then are judged by that ideal in our
striving towards it and and you know
that causes us to reflect on ourselves
and and change and aim at the ultimate
good and I think we've lost connection
with Concepts like these and and I think
he is help people to understand them and
to pull themselves out I mean go and
look at those lectures I was going to
kill myself I was addicted to drugs I
didn't talk to my father for five years
the the amount of good that came out of
that is is
um and frankly I think it was the best
social movement that happened since Ron
Paul all and I think there's a lot to
learn from it if he can become an
international cultural phenomenon off a
core message of responsibility we can
[ __ ] do it with libertarianism is
that something that you think has been
missing from the libertarian party's
message is that uh you know the message
of personal responsibility and like
strong I mean Libertarians are all
individualists but
um it's really that that's kind of a
it's a Transcendent message it
transcends politics but uh is that
something that you think there should be
more emphasis on uh politically or or is
that outside scope of politics oh yeah
because there's there's this kind of um
um paradoxical relationship with freedom
uh where freedom and responsibility
where freedom is
um taking full responsibility for your
life but but then as you have that
freedom and you pick your path in life
part of maturation is restraining your
is it's self-government it's training
your own freedom and and kind of locking
off all or blocking all of the other
paths to focus in on the things that
imbue your life with meaning or or
Advance your life or Advance your
family's life and that's that's why
responsibility is we have to be able to
take that responsibility for ourselves
we can't have that imposed Upon Us by
the state and I think this is the level
that libertarian is missing uh is is
that we're all ideas and no narrative no
story and and I think by telling a story
about no freedom is taking ultimate
responsibility for our life so that we
can imbue our lives with the most
meaning possible
um you know I think that has that that
can absolutely animate people is there a
tension between
um you know uh somebody like Robert
nozick the philosopher talked about uh a
Utopia of Utopias and he kind of talked
about uh a minute a minimal state if
that a night Watchman say if necessary
would be uh you know would be there to
allow people to kind of do their own
thing as much as possible and then
minimize friction points but when you
say that if you have a vision of Freedom
that is uh you know say it's a Christian
Community which follows very traditional
social uh and sexual rules and things
like that
um and that's there and then somebody
next door to them is living a very
libertine in a Playboy Mansion lifestyle
is that uh you know is libertarian able
to contain that kind of framework or
does it kind of trend towards a single
morality under the banner of truth that
this is the best way to live uh
I think that's for the individual I
think again we're like we're
we're it's it's like something I said
earlier where libertarianism is not a
full scale or a full form worldview it's
a political and legal Theory
um I do think that there are certain
certain ideas that would like a basic
respect for property rights that's kind
of got to be there like to maintain
um a Libertarian Society
um but again we're social animals
another thing I love about Jordan
Peterson is is um he helped me to
revolutionize how important the first
amendment in free speech is it's not
just our ability to say what we want and
speak truth to power and all that kind
of stuff it's our it's a Divine
principle for how we can disseminate
reality and and and
um disseminate what works and what does
not work
um so the kind of thing that you're
getting at has got to all play out in
the social Marketplace you know maybe it
is the case that if you live a libertine
lifestyle especially into your 30s and
Beyond and you're you're breaking
people's hearts and you know maybe there
is a relationship between that and and
people becoming bitter and resentful and
then not living the best life that they
can maybe there is but that is that for
the state of course not but this is why
we have to build up organic leaders are
you a um are you a religious person
uh if you're going to hate my answer for
this um not really not religious I'm
spiritual
it's interesting you mentioned
um you know Pro that property rights is
really just a basic respect for property
rights is kind of the thing that all
Libertarians can agree on I think that
something like that is probably right
um it but it does make me wonder like
what is the relationship that you see
between libertarianism and like
decentralism because this project is
called you know uh project uh
decentralized
um and it's like what is
um like how far down does the
decentralization go
um and like what are you willing to
compromise from a Libertarian
perspective to achieve decentralization
I guess a simpler way to put it is can
you decentralize into authoritarianism
because you can imagine
Breaking Free of some of the uh Vic tots
of the federal government but then
you're stuck with the state government
that's actually worse from a Libertarian
perspective than is the federal
government because at least we have you
know the Bill of Rights protecting us at
this point so like what if a state uh
like if a state broke away and it
decided uh really property rights are
not sacrosanct
um and uh you know eminent domain on
steroids uh is what what goes here
um is that a danger of being too
dogmatic about decentralization
mises himself would tell you if this
right of self-determination could apply
to every individual it must be so
um so again it goes again it goes back
to an earlier part of the conversation
you aim for the ideal and and again this
is this is a principle that's outlined
in rothbard's article the case for
radical idealism and it can be summed up
as you aim for the ideal and along the
way you take what you can get but you
always aim at that ideal
um I would argue that when you say like
okay let's say you decentralize
um and you in a state secedes could it
be worse from a Libertarian perspective
um you know then the federal government
broke away from I I gotta be honest I I
understand what you're going there like
some bad things could happen at a state
by state level I've never seen a state
government starve 80 of Yemen to death I
don't think they're capable of doing
that I've never seen a state government
drop nuclear bombs on on Japan before I
don't think they're capable of doing
that what about online
I'm not saying they're Angels the
American Military that is that that's um
the big evil that you're you're hoping
to abolish here
um I I I can understand that perspective
however domestically
um you know you can imagine states that
would strip away all Second Amendment
rights you can imagine ones that would
strip away First Amendment rights and
second amendment rights due process all
these things are like states are
constantly trying to do this and pretty
much the only thing that stops them is
you know constitutional challenges I I
had a little bit state governments have
yeah state governments have
constitutions just the same as the
federal government and what is it doing
for the federal government you know what
I mean like we still have state I I I
mean my state we have a stronger Second
Amendment than the Federal Constitution
in terms of decentralization though
would would say with gun rights because
this is playing out in certain states
that are trying to devolve gun rights
certain types of gun rights decisions to
the local level would it be okay uh if a
local Town said you know what we are
absolutely going gun free we are giving
the police an absolute you know properly
on force and we're going to go house by
house and you know and you guys opted in
you you know you're living here you
voted for us who voted for this is I
mean it would you be are you in favor of
decentralization even when the uh you
know the outcome is anti-libertarian as
most people would Define I would I would
say I'm not in favor of ill liberal
policy ever
um but I do think that a a like a
problem like that like gun control it's
better if it's isolated to one state
than it is the whole freaking country so
you always have to put up that fight but
you see I would say you see a lot more
Hope on a state-by-state level than you
ever do from the feds the feds just
conspired with the NIH and all the big
corporations to like essentially
socially coerce this vaccine and and
there's all sorts of problems associated
with that now whereas even in New York
which is like a ill liberal hellscape
had a um the court decision to reverse
their their gun stuff so like there's
always going to be this tension between
liberal liberalism in the classical
sense and Ill liberalism but the
question is where does the fight become
more manageable a a federal government
that is trending ever more towards
supernational international government
or or at the state level and down and
down and down it varies right because it
it depends because there were various
speech rights that were enforced
ultimately by the federal government
certain civil rights I mean if you were
black in the South and you wanted to go
to a good Public School you were [ __ ]
until the feds or you know are an
equally bad you know uh Public School
the feds did play a role there so
um cannot two quick things and then
we're going to wrap up can I ask you one
question on that front would you say
that the federal government is a net is
a net rights protector or a net rights
violation I I don't think I don't I
think that's the wrong way to look at it
in the same way that uh States and local
governments are the the way that we win
we are kind of like you know uh uh uh
Clint Eastwood and uh you know The Good
the Bad and the Ugly you're constantly
working one government against another
another government against another
government against people in order to
get like the the biggest fear of
individual rights and autonomy so I you
know on on certain levels the federal
government has been great on certain
levels state governments have been great
and then sometimes you have like you
know third sector groups like The you
know the Catholic Church which in one
place could be totally repressive and
another can be an agent of uh freedom
and Liberation so
um yeah I just want to comment last
comment I will say this just to kind of
set the set the table on this I am an
opportunist
um we don't have a lot of avenues
available to us so if while we got the
feds if I can get a good outcome with it
and [ __ ] it I mean I'm aimed at
decentralization but but I'll uh we're
we're under a lot of duress and
decentralization is a tool not an end in
itself
uh yeah I mean yeah I would agree with
that the goal is more more Liberty I
just think that um it's much easier to
fight for liberalism when it's your city
council just to go back to Jordan
Peterson briefly you said you know the
the you you uh you know like The
Connoisseur of of a fine band you know
an underground band that became popular
you like his early work
um what happened in 2019 uh and his kind
of you know his journey which may or may
not be indicative of everybody who kind
of believes has thought but like he is
now working you know for what on The
Daily wire he is a conservative pundit
it's like has he become less interesting
why has it become less interesting uh I
I think so in terms of his politics what
he would identify with and has publicly
identified with
um is he calls himself a classical
liberal he specifically says I'm a
British classical liberal so I don't
think he's the worst guy in the world I
also think that he has shown um a huge
willingness to change in the in the face
of new data I mean I personally handed
the guy a copy of Choice by by Bob
Murphy next thing you know he's having
suffodina moose and Bob Murphy on the
show saying I'm interested in the
Austrian School you know he took the
vaccine and then basically said hey um I
took the vaccine and now the state won't
leave me alone what the [ __ ]
um so I I think you know I I think he's
his own man
um and and uh now in terms of your
question
I'm not I'm not nearly as interested in
his political commentary as as uh
archetype myth meaning narrative uh uh
neuro neuro uh chemistry and all of this
kind of stuff and I suspect that what
he's going to find over time is that is
the stuff that a lot of his audience
came to him for because it imbued their
life with meaning and that they're not
they're not interested in more politics
[Music]
thank you
uh Zach
um there's one question here that maybe
we can uh finish up on uh Amanda Gibbs
can Michael tell us about his classes at
The mises Institute so this is your your
chance to plug uh Mike on our on our way
out
um well I don't have classes at The
mises Institute i i attended mises
University and I I uh think everybody
should mises University was an
absolutely fantastic experience
um but um okay maybe maybe we can talk
about uh whatever candidate training
that the amuses caucus oh that's that
might be what she's asking about gotcha
yeah I guess I'll just say for the
record that we're not formally
associated with The mises Institute we
all just love them
um but um but yeah run is
libertarian.com if you are interested in
running for office we'll give you the
training no matter what you're running
for
um but uh we will try to get you to run
for local office because we think that's
the most valuable
um but yeah Runners libertarian.com
that's uh where we're funneling all the
candidates and and uh you know
connecting them to our organizers for on
the ground support connecting them to
training right now at a clip it twice a
month
um and then we're also going to be doing
in-person training at our take Human
Action tour events
okay thank you Mike
um any anything else Nick before we uh
get out of here uh you know uh can we uh
just to try and throw uh one more Log on
the Fire
um do you have uh you you know you've
talked about the the the need to
radically decentralize to sub-county
level races but there's also a role for
national uh races and uh people running
for offices
um I know that you've said in the past
that uh Dave Smith and Maj Torre would
be the ideal LP ticket in uh 2024. do
you still believe that and if so make
the pitch
I 100 believe that because
um I think the two of them combined
especially are in positions that nobody
else in the Liberty Movement is in
um I think you know Dave has been on Dr
Drew I haven't never seen any other
libertarian on there he's been he's
forming relationships with Pat David
he's forming a relationship to Tucker
Carlson he's friends with Joe Rogan he's
been on with Megyn Kelly they love him
over at tin pool uh he's on Kennedy he's
on Greg Gutfeld he is just on more
platforms and in front of more people
effectively giving the message by a
large margin than anybody else in the
movement I don't really think that's Up
For Debate and and um you know so I
think he has the the ability to speak to
the most people and get them excited
about our ideas and and be in that
funnel likewise I think Maj Torre has a
huge platform and and legitimacy to
crowds that
um we just don't have access to you know
like uh you know he he's uh he shouted
out by a track uh in a track by name by
Royce to five nine who was a major
rapper has done Duo albums with Eminem
you know what I mean like uh he's he's
done debates with Lupe Fiasco he's and
another thing that Maj brings to the
table is that like it's one thing for
Libertarians to be let's say principally
good on an issue and and to be seen as
legitimate in the eyes of the people who
care about that issue so like for
example it's one thing for us to be
second amendment absolute systems to
speak that principle it's another thing
for Maj Torre to be respected by all of
the gun uh trainers around the country
and the ammo producers around the
country and and Cole and Noir and you
know all of these people you know it's
it's not just the ideas it's the
legitimacy it's one thing to be
interviewed by Joe Rogan it's another
thing to be interviewed by Joe Rogan who
is your friend and colleague in comedy
where there's like this transference of
legitimacy
and and I and I think that when you put
the two of those together we can reach
tens of millions of people uh and and
and effectively at that and I think
that's going to flood us with the most
number of people and get as many people
have the most political Capital that
we've ever had and start nullifying and
and you know having these pockets of
resistance around the country
the one uh the criticism that that comes
to mind there is that
um and you know you say this explicitly
in the document that we got to kind of
get rid of this uh idea that uh yeah
we're we're in it to win it that we have
any shot whatsoever it just makes us
sound like crazy and delusional that
that's always what the libertarian Party
candidate has traditionally said is like
yeah I've got a shot at this actually uh
Harry Brown kind of initiated that in
his book why government doesn't work in
96 said that explicitly as well as an
interview to me at reason at the time
but right before that they usually said
we are running informational campaigns
let me give you an example of of
something in this realm that I thought
was very eye-opening and apparently I'm
the only one who saw this I've never
heard anyone else mention this moment
but when Justin Amash dipped his toe
into the presidential race in 2020 he
got a Bill Maher interview
um and that's great
in that interview like I think it was
right at the outset Bill Maher asked him
so why what are you doing do you think
you can win this race and Amash said
something to the effect of like well
yeah of course I'm running you know I I
don't think I I if I wasn't if I didn't
think I could win I wouldn't be running
something like that and Bill Maher
laughed at him he laughed at him and
basically said yeah well you know you
guys come around every four years you
always have a story and it always sounds
the same I really think he's speaking to
how normal people do and I think we
gotta
I think we've got to embrace the fact
that the role of these races is
different than winning I I think we have
to embrace the fact that we are just
pitching a different Paradigm and we're
being a thorn in their side and [ __ ]
these people and but you know like I I
really think that we've got to just
Embrace what the role of that is and it
ain't winning not yet what what is the
like value proposition for somebody
anybody to cast a ballot for somebody
who is like yeah I'm not even this is
not really a serious uh candidacy
uh there isn't one right now and I think
we have to be honest about that we don't
I mean why why would they if they if
they know that we're not going to win
and they see Team a is as being more
dangerous than Team B and they have to
defend themselves from that
um
we don't like basically the only value
ad that we have is changing the Paradigm
that like and I mean what to you guys is
the value of it I I I think I mean like
because there's a lot of time and money
that is spent you know getting on
ballots and so forth so like what what
really would be the point of that
um if your objective is not really to
win votes
I mean I think we can incorporate that
we got to say listen if you love these
ideas like if you want to be a thorn in
these side give us your vote we need we
want you on the ballot but or whether we
on the ballot to cause this trouble and
to disrupt but we're not going to win
and nobody thinks we're going to win
sounds kind of like Gary Johnson in
2016.
I would say it was more 2012 Gary
Johnson who was a lot better
um we are uh uh we're going to wrap up
this has been a lot of fun and it's been
very long I think this is our longest
live stream uh to date Zach uh yeah
flew right by though I want to uh do a
quick shout out to a GMM for his five
dollar donation in question uh Michael
ice
um yeah should we bring that up just
since he threw in five bucks all right
yeah yeah is Michael familiar with Edwin
vieira's proposal that each state
legalized gold and silver in order to
undermine the Fed
I am and um legislation to do just that
sample legislation to do just that is
available on the 10th Amendment Center's
website and then you also have the
Missouri Freedom Coalition uh who is
working to do exactly that
um so yeah I totally think that's
something we should do and I think
Bitcoin should be uh
in that conversation as well
um okay uh let's uh leave it here
Michael Heiss of the mises caucus thanks
for talking to reason and uh you know
we'll see you around
thanks guys take Human Action